Bangladesh says there are about 1.2
million rohingya refugees living in
camps in the country Bangladesh's
foreign minister has told me that in
recent days a delegation from the
military regime in Myanmar met
Bangladeshi officials to arrange a pilot
scheme to start returning some of them
the area they come from
that area relatively okay but if they go
back and say if the government they can
help stabilizing the situation after all
their Myanmar people
remarkably it's emerged that when the
Myanmar delegation traveled to
Bangladesh their transport was provided
by the United Nations to U.N agencies
the world food program and unhcr
provided boats the Insignia were removed
for the journey and it's reported that
there were weapons on board hidden under
tarpaulins
when I spoke to the un's special Envoy
for Myanmar about all of this she
restated the organization's
long-standing position that no refugees
should be sent back until there are
conditions which are conducive to their
voluntary dignified and safe return we
are not satisfied that those conditions
are there at this particular time the
generals who carried out a coup now seem
to at least on one occasion have a navy
and that Navy is the United Nations that
must worry you well if they had
consulted me I would have stopped it
but nobody consulted me
Myanmar pro-democracy activists and
human rights campaigners say they're
very concerned about recent events the
use of U.N boats would appear to be a
breach of the organization's neutrality
and they say the UN shouldn't be doing
anything to facilitate the return of
refugees because conditions remain too
unsafe James Bays Al Jazeera of the
United Nations